[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and after
looking at all of today's announcements
after compiling and analyzing it all and
looking through every single thing here
it is and here we go this is the best of
the best these are the top five features
of android 4.4 kitkat technically this
is only a 0.1 update from android 4.3
but for those of you who thought this
was going to be a super minor update
that didn't really matter think again
there's a lot of awesome stuff going on
here so i'll have a whole bunch of links
right below that like button for all of
the important things that'll cover
everything i'm talking about but without
any further ado check this out number
five is the dialer and i think a lot of
us forget that ultimately the
smartphones that we used today were
originally designed to place and receive
phone calls so the dialer is improved in
android 4.4 and it's improved in both
the functionality and the design the
design is different because it is uh
first of all it organizes your most
frequently contacted people up at the
top by default so that's nice and
convenient and also brings a new flat
clean simple design that we'll see more
in android but we'll get to that in a
second but the functionality now is also
upgraded it acts as a search box in the
most convenient way possible so right
now there's a search box up at the top
of the contacts app if you want to
search a friend whose name is eric or
something you can type in eric and it'll
find eric's contact but if you want to
search for a local business or a local
place that's near you like a starbucks
you can type in coffee in the search app
and it'll find the nearest places that
serve coffee near you from google maps
it'll give you their phone numbers and
of course their names that is very
convenient number four is nfc mimicking
it's called host card emulation and
basically what this does is it allows
any device running kitkat whether it has
an nfc chip or not to emulate nfc based
transactions so you can read and write
nfc whether you have the chip or not
this will hopefully be beneficial to
bringing the ability to use nfc stuff
like mobile payments to as many devices
as possible now a lot of the new devices
that get android 4.4 kitkat will
probably have an nfc chip anyway but
when this gets to older devices that
don't have nfc chips they'll be able to
use all sorts of awesome features i did
a video specifically called the top five
best things you can do with nfc all the
awesome features so you can check out
that annotation or click the link in the
description where i have that video so
if you want to check out all the awesome
stuff that nfc and nfc based
transactions can do for you
that's where it is number three is the
design update and it's this is all about
the looks basically here uh kitkat has
changed a lot of the elements that we've
gotten used to in android since like
android 4.0 with the very hollow look
but they're a lot flatter they're a lot
simpler and i really like a lot of them
most notable is the new transparency of
the buttons along the bottom and the
notification bar up top and also the
gray new time and battery icon and all
the indicators up top are also now that
flat gray look there's also a slightly
adjusted system-wide font in android all
the different stock apps are updated
with android and they all have this new
clean design to them and even the touch
responsiveness on the bottom buttons is
is much neater it's much more subtle so
overall it has a very nice cleaned up
look that i like to but it definitely
keeps the beautiful it keeps the
beautiful hollow stuff it brings full
screen album art to your lock screen
when listening to music it brings also
these new full screen apps that can take
advantage of hiding your system icon
buttons and your notifications up top
and basically immerses you in this full
immersion mode is what they call it and
actually now brand new to stock android
you can actually tap the screen swipe
down from the top to find those
notifications in a full screen app you
couldn't do this on android before but
now when you're gaming if your phone
buzzes you have to close the app to
check to see what that notification was
now you can swipe down in immersion mode
and find it so overall there is a
flatter cleaner look to all the apps
inside of kitkat and the operating
system itself and i like the new look
and i think it's very subtle but it's
also a definite improvement from android
4.3 to 4.4 number two is streamlined
performance and this is arguably the
most important update to all of android
4.4 kitkat in fact when you take a look
at the blog post and the official page
announcing the new update it says at the
top of the blog post kitkat brings all
of android's most innovative most
beautiful and most useful features to
more devices everywhere now they're not
actually doing this like giving you the
newest version of android but they are
facilitating this by seriously lowering
the system requirements of android 4.4
kitkat and this is a big deal because
usually going from an older version of
an os to a newer one the system
requirements naturally get bumped up as
technology moves forward but the newest
version of android will run smoother
faster and more efficient and more
responsively on devices with as little
as half a gigabyte of ram the os itself
is much more memory efficient and
they've streamlined major components of
android so the whole thing including
multitasking will be much faster and
they've introduced new apis to help your
favorite developers make great apps that
will run smooth and more responsive on
way more devices especially those with
lower specs this kind of makes specs
even less important than they were
before there's also even this new
built-in setting called process stats so
you know how before you could see
exactly how much storage each app was
using on your android device so you
could tell when you filled up your
internal storage they're going to have
this app called process stats which will
look like the same thing for your ram so
you can see exactly how much ram your
individual running applications are
using and it'll give you a better
contextual idea a better visual of well
whether or not you need more ram if you
bought a device that can't quite handle
all your multitasking or if you're doing
just fine with one or two gigabytes now
in terms of bringing this to more
devices uh it's launching right now on
the nexus 5 which is shipping now so you
can go get one um and i think they
really missed out on a huge opportunity
here to update their nexus s and their
galaxy nexus even to this latest version
to really show how serious they are
about supporting older phones and lower
end specs but they're not as far as we
know right now they're updating the
nexus 4 nexus 7 and nexus 10. the google
play editions are going to be right
afterwards and soon right after that
we'll see carriers and manufacturers
start to announce when their updates are
going to roll out to their devices and
that brings us to number one which is
google search and google now
smarter
everywhere first of all in your home
screen on the launcher you'll be able to
swipe all the way to the left and get to
google now which is very conveniently
accessed similar to the way that global
search was inside ios 6 and of course
you can also still swipe up from the
bottom soft buttons to also get to
google now and on the snapdragon 800
nexus 5 you're going to be able to just
start saying ok google and it'll start
opening the google search and searching
so it'll be constantly listening to you
when you're on your home screen and this
is as far as we know only the nexus 5
because of that snapdragon 800 enabling
it so it won't hit battery life but
that's pretty cool that it's there and
like i said the new contacts app is also
basically a google search app the dialer
will let you search through google maps
and local business listings and there
are a ton more improvements new cards
and new optimizations into google now i
called google now personally one of the
best products of 2012 and it seems like
google realizes how important and how
unique and how good this product is and
they're putting a lot of effort and
research into making this a better
product for 2013 and that's easily why
it gets number one pretty much no other
company has a product as powerful as
this that ties into other google
services and that has so much potential
especially so the more google develops
this the more i'm going to talk about
how great it is because i've done
separate videos about how good google
now is and it's awesome and i encourage
you to check it out if you haven't
already now of course this wouldn't be
complete without some honorable mentions
so i got to give a shout out to the
hangouts app which is being updated
alongside kitkat because it is getting
sms and mms support so in the newest
version of android it's actually the
default messaging app so it'll be in
your dock you're gonna be seeing a lot
more of hangouts now and i actually like
that because the default messaging app
before really isn't all that great it's
pretty bare so i'm proud of how far
hangouts has come in such a short period
of time and now it'll be the default
hangouts and sms and mms app i got to
give another mention to the new sms api
it sounds boring but once you realize
how good it is it's great usually before
when you want to set a new third-party
sms app messaging app you have to
disable the notifications in one and
then enable the notifications in the
other to fully switch over it's going to
be one click now with the new api in
kitkat so if you want to set some other
third-party sms app as your default
it'll literally be sending those
messages directly into that third-party
app you don't have to worry about
switching on and off notifications it'll
go directly into your app of choice so
if you don't like hangouts you can use
some other messaging app and it'll be
your default and it'll only take one
click and there's even more little
things like there's going to be the
emojis now everywhere where you'll use
that google keyboard and you'll be able
to print pretty much anything on any
printer with google cloud print enabled
there's a new downloads app the old one
was really quite bare so this one's much
more organized
and kitkat will also now support
pedometers ir blasters and all sorts of
other low-powered sensors so there's
lots of little tweaks behind the scenes
here and even littler things like when
you get a phone call from a number that
google sees in maps is a local business
it'll do an image search and find a
relevant image to that business and show
that as the caller id along with the
name of the business so even if you
don't have that business in your
contacts you will get a photo and a name
in your caller id because google knows
that that's a business it seems by
reading the literature that this newest
version of android 4.4 is all about
enabling
older devices and lower end lower
powered devices so for older devices
it's going to be all about those
carriers and those manufacturers
bringing out those updates even this
moto x here which is basically on almost
stock android is still running android
4.2 so it would have to leapfrog 4.3 to
get the 4.4 update and that's the case
with a lot of other older devices i
think google if they want this to happen
they really have to push this and make
this the number one thing they talk
about to those carriers and
manufacturers
if their relationship is square
hopefully older devices
almost as old as the galaxy nexus will
be getting kitkat overall it seems like
this is a very solid upgrade to android
this might not be an overhaul if you
will uh but this new android is
definitely smarter more efficient and
very much more google so there you go be
sure to share this video out for people
who are wondering about the new android
4.4 update or wondering what the
operating system has anything to do with
this is a video to share with them so
that share button is below thank you for
watching and i will talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
[Music]
you